the Joe Rogan experience oh you're very
welcome it's very cool people let you
know a Kevin brought our giant heavy bag
filled with sand that has Dawei North of
200 pounds oh yeah I think it's about
250 yeah a lot of fun getting that in my
car by myself is that your preferred
method for conditioning your shins for
sure for sure you know the thing with
Qing conditioning a lot of people do you
know they smack themselves in the shin
with bottles and kind of stupid things
like that yeah you're not really
creating what you need to which is a
overall conditioning overall
strengthening of the nerve the bone all
you're really doing is dead any little
spots in your nerves but that's the
worst thing you do without strengthening
your bones you're deadening the nerves
but not strengthening the bone overall
and if you're not doing that you're
gonna think your bones a lot stronger
than it is but it can't handle the
impact so with with a sandbag or your
you're covering much more surface area
and you know applying it in a realistic
situation where you're you're able to
throw kicks repeatedly at this thing and
what you would you really want to do is
do it to a degree that it's causing a
certain amount of pain but you're able
to do this daily with with repetition
because that's how you continue to
develop just like getting stronger at
anything you know again it doesn't
happen overnight you got to just do this
every day just at the end of your
session knock out a few kicks and then
again tomorrow and again the next day
and you slowly and steadily are able to
go harder and harder and develop this
strength and conditioning in your shins
so the idea is that you're making like
these little tiny micro fractures right
yeah for sure and yeah like I said you
want to be able to cover a good surface
area so you're hitting it all it kind of
at once as opposed to like little spots
which is what happens when we just whack
it with a batter or something like that
my experience was whacking it with a bat
is everybody kind of quits you're like
hey I'm gonna condition my shins and
then they just go what the [ __ ] am i
doing and they stopped doing it well the
thing to with with when you're able to
kick like that is
you can kind of slowly build up you know
you start a little bit lightly and
develop a little bit stronger and you
kind of create a little bit of a crease
and you know as you get going you your
brain can kind of wrap itself around it
a little bit better and then you still
going harder and harder and by the end
of you know your five ten-minute session
you're putting some serious weight into
that and you're not you're not noticing
it as much yeah we were talking about
your your need that you had a fracture
in your knee that you didn't realize you
had yeah that's this it's weird like the
thing that disturbs me maybe the most in
kickboxing and so I've only seen it a
few times is when someone checks a kick
and their leg snaps in half you know
like Tyrone Spong when you fly gokon
sake or Anderson Silva when he fought
Chris Weidman anything that snap of when
the the shin gives out like that can you
prevent that from doing this obviously
it's one of those just freak things that
happens you know clearly with those guys
you can have the most conditioned Chin's
in the world but you catch them the
wrong way wrong time they can happen in
it's rare but it does happen and it
doesn't really matter how long you've
been doing this how strong your shins
are sometimes things just break I always
wonder how many guys have little breaks
and they don't know about it - right a
lot yeah a lot yeah they said that's
what happened with Anderson and Anderson
threw a kick and he broke it before that
like he felt something was wrong and
then we threw that second kick and it
snapped in half that's that's why I did
that yeah yeah that makes sense
well Weidman was checking it perfect he
was checking it right at the top of his
knee yeah and you know that's a big
thing with you know fighting a lot of a
lot of people tend to just blindly just
pick their shin up you know as opposed
to paying attention to where it is on
your shin that it's hitting just just
like when you're kicking you need to pay
attention to what piece of your leg
you're hitting with which piece of your
shin you're checking with and the higher
up on your shin it is the harder it's
going to be and when you're southpaw
versus orthodoxson throwing that inside
leg kick you're you're coming up words
at an angle which is tends to be like
low on your foot or your your your ankle
and then your check
with high up by your knee so you have
the smallest part of your shin
connecting with the the hardest part of
somebody else's and with that that's
just the one that tends to do that yeah
it's a shin on shin contact is such a
brutal thing like I think everybody
should experience it once yeah you know
just crack ah yeah and you know the
funny thing is it doesn't matter how
long you've you've done this for you we
watch these fights and assume that they
don't feel pain and that it doesn't
bother them but even guys with hundreds
and hundreds of fights you've seen the
next day and they're gimping around
pretty good yeah you know we have this
idea in our brains that eventually
you're gonna get to a point when you
just don't feel pain and it doesn't
bother you but eventually realize that
never happens you know it is better to
get that out of your head
now you know Muay Thai and kickboxing
and anything that the bone-on-bone is
it's going to be painful and that's part
of the art of it you learn how to place
your kicks better and pay attention to
what you're doing and yeah of course you
you develop your shin conditioning and
that kind of thing but it always hurts
it's always going to hurt
[Applause]